So overall, I think the interview
candidate marketed pretty well.
He asked a lot of clarifying questions.
Asking the clarifying questions like
really trying to understand the problem.
A lot of times as an interviewer,
you have an idea of where you want
him to go, but getting him to
that point is his responsibility.
He has to ask those questions
to get himself there.
I think he also did a really good job
of following my lead like when I was
trying to get him somewhere
of actually like listening to
the feedback that he was given and
going down those roads.
Yes, so I think a little more white
board practice would have helped
him out.
You tend to want to start in
the top left of the board.
That way,
you have plenty of room to write.
You want to make sure that you
leave space between lines,
because you're always going to have to
go back and add lines in the middle.
And then there were opportunities
where he would close out a tag and
then he'd have to erase it and move
that closing down further and further,
as we progress through the problem.
So I would say,
give yourself more space for writing and
don't close the tag until you're done.
So the teach me something in five minute
question, I really like that one.
Because as an engineer,
you're constantly having to
teach your fellow engineers.
There's not an engineer on the face of
the Earth that it was everything about
everything.
So, they're constantly
helping each other and.
Teaching someone something they don't
know in five minutes is actually
a really important part of the job
that you'll do numerous times per day.
So I asked about what interested
in web development and
what he was excited about
coming down in the future, and
that's a question looking for
passion and drive.
This is a career field
that's constantly changing.
And if someone's not passionate about
the field or the product itself,
they're not going to remain
on the cutting edge.
So it's a question
designed to determine,
if they're going to
be someone that will.
Stay educated and
remain at the cutting edge the whole
time they're with your company.
So, the question about the palindrome is
a pretty typical programming question
you'll receive.
The interviewer's not too interested
in whether you can actually solve
the problem, they just want to see if
you can think like a programmer and
if you understand the basic syntax
rules of the language being used.
So the image carousel question is
another basic programming question
that's just trying, it's pretty simple.
So, we're just trying to get the
candidate warmed up at that point and
get used to writing on the board.
And once again, we're just trying to
see if they think like that a developer
would within the role
though be fulfilled.
So, the question on closures is actually
the one question that I was actually
testing the candidate's
understanding of the language on.
It gets pretty low level and we ask some
deep questions that really let me know
whether the candidate knows what's
going on when they're writing code.
So the question about the technical
challenge and how did you solve it,
that's kind of a cool-down question
coming off of the whiteboard.
And just let's me understand some of the
things that the candidate has challenge
themselves with and
how do they approach that problem, and
their problem solving ability.
And I really want to see the candidate
get through a complicated problem and
not say, well, I had this problem and
I just gave up or I went and
asked someone for help.
Overall, the tone was good.
Probably could have slowed
down a little bit and
thought about the response to a question
a little more before answering it.
Particularly there were moments where it
felt like the candidate was going on and
on and on a little bit and they probably
could've just wrapped it up quicker.